the bulls are in town the world's best
bull riders are too
rodeo athletes are back for the
professional bull riders competition
this will be the pbr's first vegas event
with fans since
november 2019. we sent hector mejia out
to well check it out and ra
wave the red flag he's out there live
this morning
hector uh give us a look at those bulls
i noticed they wanted the camera on
their good side not their bad side
what's going on out there this morning
yeah well a lot is going on you know
we're waking up the animals this morning
it's an exciting morning with days and
it's friday it's a beautiful friday and
check out this beautiful animal right
here
we're waking them up some are in a great
mood just smiling at us looking at us
with their beautiful eyes others
are looking a little more groggy and
grumpy this morning because it is pretty
early for them
and as we highlight pbr coming back to
town we're also talking about
a historic partnership with bill pickett
invitational rodeo
the only touring national tour with
all black uh athletes and joining us
live we have michaela to talk about not
just that but all right
what's in store for you this weekend
because i understand you are competing i
am i'm competing in the barrel race um
so it's very exciting to be here in las
vegas
um of course the nfr goes on here i
don't want pbr events so
it's just the prestigious las vegas what
is
barrel racing like um it is a ton of fun
you have to be a little bit of an
adrenaline junkie but
you have to be an adrenaline junkie to
ride these bulls too that's true so
i guess that's kind of the name of the
game but
um you know girl racing is set up in a
clove relief shape pattern and
fastest time wins michaela how
significant is this partnership
um it's a big step like you said the
bill pickets um
all african-american and to be
partnering with something
as prestigious and big as pdr um it's a
big step in representing
african american athletes well thank you
for joining us this early in the morning
thank you and good luck to you this
weekend thank you you're welcome all
right so we'll be uh talking with
more people this morning and showing you
around the grounds here and let's take a
look over here
another beautiful bull right there just
resting and just
enjoying the shade anyway we'll be back
in less than half an hour
for now reporting live hector mejia 8
news now back to you guys